PROFESSOR: Let's then try
to understand intuitively
some issues with phase shift.
And that, I think,
is pretty valuable.
One shouldn't rush
through these things.
I'm going to erase
this formula already.
It's a little messy.
It's not like you're
going to use it ever.
You could use that
formula if you were
to compute higher phase shifts.
But at least this homework,
you don't have that.
So let's try to
understand a little
what phase shifts do for you.
Phase shifts are useful when the
first few phase shifts dominate
the cross section.
If you have to do this
sum for all values of l,
it can get very difficult.
So if the answer really
necessitates the tail of l
going to infinity, it's hard.
So in general, we
find that phase shifts
are useful when the first few
dominate the cross section.
So phase shifts are useful if
the first few dominate sigma.
And that will tend to happen
when k a is much less than 1.
And this will
happen in that case.
That will be our argumentation.
We will try to explain why
when k a is less than 1,
this will happen.
So what is k a less than 1?
Well, it could be
that a is very small.
So one possibility
is short range,
which means a small
compared to other scales,
and maybe there is a problem.
Or the other possibility
is that low energy.
That is, k is small, because
energy goes like k squared.
If k is small, it's low energy.
So these are the
possibilities that
would allow us to
have a situation where
only the first few
phase shifts contribute
to the cross section.
So let's see why
that is the case
and what is the
intuition for this.
This happens for--
I think I want to add
here this happens when--
so the claim above happens
when k a is less than 1.
Let's have a picture of this.
Consider an incident
particle on a potential.
So here is a potential.
Here is r equals 0 and
this is the potential.
Maybe some region-- here's
an incident particle
coming in with some momentum.
So these ideas are
semi-classical ideas on how
I'm looking at this particle
coming with some impact
parameter. b is this distance
to the center, the maximum--
the closest approach of the
particle to the potential.
That's called the
impact parameter.
And it has momentum p.
So b is the impact parameter
and p is the momentum.
And then, what is the angular
momentum of this particle
with respect to the origin?
Is r cross p.
And so the angular
momentum l is equal to bp.
OK.
So now I'm going to try to
make sense of this equation
and get an estimate,
considering our situation.
So what is our situation?
In our situation, when we
consider a partial wave
expansion, we're
considering waves
with different values of the
orbital angular momentum l.
So when we consider
a little l, we're
really saying that the angular
momentum is proportional to hl,
where l is the quantum number.
Number.
The number that we're
fixing here each time
we talk about the partial wave.
Moreover, if we're asking
about the momentum,
we know what is the
typical momentum
of these waves-- it's hk.
So if I substitute those
two pieces of information
into the relation of the
angular momentum here--
so l is equal to hl and
b multiplies h bar k,
we get that the impact parameter
can be visualized as l over k.
It's a somewhat
classical intuition.
But it gives you an idea.
As you're increasing l, you're
increasing the impact parameter
intuitively.
A partial wave
scattering process with l
reflects the input parameter.
If l is equal to 0, you're
hitting the object right on.
And now, you can say, all
right, if b is greater than a,
where a is the range
of the potential--
range-- there should be
little or no scattering.
So if b is greater than a,
is little or no scattering.
That's intuitively clear from
the range of the potential.
If the input parameter
is much bigger.
So this means l greater than
k a, there is no scattering.
And this physically-- this
is classical intrusion
suggests that the contribution
to scattering from l's
bigger than k a is negligible.
There's no scattering.
So this is saying that sigma--
how should I say it?
The delta l-- I'll just say
delta l's are small or very
small--
small-- for l greater than k a.
The delta l, the phase
shifts, enter here,
as sine squared of
the phase shifts.
So they must be very small,
because they just pretty much
don't contribute.
This is intuition we
were claiming up there.
If k a is rather small, very few
phase shifts will contribute.
Because as soon as your
l is bigger than k a,
you get nothing.
If k a is much less than 1,
only l equals 0 will contribute.
If k a is 1 or 2, it's--
I think I would write here, if--
we don't have to be very
small, but around 1, very few
will contribute.
Or essentially, you could say
that all the l less than k
contribute.
They contribute.
So even if k a, say, was 5, you
could hope that the l's up to 5
will be a big contribution.
And after that, they
start to fall off.
OK.
So that's one
intuition into the l's.
Second piece of intuition
comes from the solutions
that you have of
the real equation.
So it's interesting, actually.
Let's look at our
partial waves directly.
Second intuition for this fact--
think of your solution
Jl of kr, Yl of theta.
This is a solution.
Represents a partial wave.
It's the one that doesn't
diverge at the origin.
So that makes some sense.
It represents a free
wave, but still is
giving us an intuition of
how this partial wave is
supposed to behave.
So I would like to
have an intuition
of how big is this function
and where it is big.
So this is a solution
of the radial equation.
A radial equation
with no potential.
That doesn't mean zero
effective potential,
because there's always
the centrifugal barrier.
So this is the solution.
Solution of the v equals
0 radial equation, which
has a potential,
which is v effective
is h squared, l times l
plus 1 over 2mr squared.
That's the effective potential.
And it's a solution with energy
h squared, k squared, over 2m.
So here is r.
Here is the effective potential.
And how does it look?
Well, it diverges
and then falls off.
And you have a solution
with energy equal h squared,
k squared, over 2m.
It's a solution of that
problem with that potential.
So here is your intuition.
This solution encounters
a barrier here.
So it must be exponentially
suppressed in this distance.
It will be
exponentially suppressed
as you go below
this turning point.
Therefore, this partial wave
will be 0 for some radius
smaller to a certain
distance here.
And that's back
of our intuition.
If you have some impact
parameter this large,
you have no support
over distances smaller
than your impact parameter.
There's no wave there.
The wave stays away.
So what we want to show is
that this wave stays away
from the center r equals 0,
again, by a quantity related
to this thing.
So what do we get?
Well, we can solve
for the turning point.
So h squared l, l plus 1
over 2mr star squared--
I can call this r star--
is equal to h squared,
k squared, over 2m.
Lots of things cancel.
2m's, h squared.
So you get kr star
squared is roughly equal
to l times l plus 1.
And here, I can
approximate and I can
say that kr star is roughly l.
That's the leading
order square root.
And therefore, the
wave function vanishes.
This Jl of kr must be
quite approximately
0 for r less than r
star equal l over k,
which is the impact parameter.
So we know because this must
be exponentially suppressed,
that the wave function
must be very much 0 here.
And that the radial
wave function is this.
So you have derived
that the Jl of kr
is essentially 0 for r less than
this r star, which is about l
over k, that we identified
after impact parameter.
So our ideas are consistent.
This partial wave
doesn't reach the origin.
It stays a bit the way.
How much?
The intuition is
that the distance
approximate to the
input parameter,
which is l divided by k.
OK.
So that's another
piece of intuition.
There's one more
classical intuition
that they think
it's interesting.
It's very surprising,
actually, this third one,
this semi-classical intuition
into what these things are.
But they're important because
the subject of phase shift
seems very technical.
But the phase shifts
have important meaning
and those partial
waves are interesting.
So let's do one more way of
thinking about these matters.
OK.
So I'd say, recall
this equation.
Sigma is given by the total
cross section-- three--
the total cross section
is given by this sum.
So sigma is the
sum of sigma l's.
And that's a nice notation.
This is the stigma associated
with each partial wave.
No, it's a good thinking.
And the sigma l is equal
to 4 pi over k squared, 2l
plus 1, sine squared of delta l.
Now, just from this formula,
when somebody gives you a sigma
l, you can know whether
they're making sense
or not, because there
is a test, at least.
Sigma l is always less than or
equal to 4 pi over k squared
times 2l plus 1.
And this just comes
because sine squared
is less than or equal to 1.
So it's a good test.
People say, oh, I found the
partial cross section given
by this for that partial wave.
Well, it better satisfy
that, otherwise, you've
done a wrong calculation.
Some people call this
partial wave unitarity.
Unitarity has to do with
conservation of probability
and cross sections
have that thing.
It's a probability to
scatter in some direction,
in some measure.
So this is called
partial wave unitarity.
Wave unitarity.
It's interesting
that these ideas
have a connection in
classical physics, again, that
allow you to think of,
actually, physically about
these processes in a way
that illuminates what's
happening quantum mechanically.
So here is how you
can think of this.
We have, again--
I'll do a nice picture.
I'll try at least.
A source here and
there's a potential.
And now I'm going to come
at some impact parameter.
But let me think
of it as coming--
here is the cylinder
of impact parameters.
If you come anywhere on the
surface of this cylinder,
you'll have input parameter b--
b is here.
Now, let's fit in the cylinder.
I'll fit in the cylinder.
To make it of thickness delta b.
Thickness.
So the thickness is delta b.
And you now consider
all these particles
that are going to come
in here and scatter.
Now, in classical
physics, you know
it's easy or reasonable
to track things,
because everything
is deterministic.
So I can imagine very well
that this shell just goes here.
And it becomes a shell
here of particles that
are going off at some angles.
So, like a trumpet.
This comes like that
and spreads out here.
And all these particles
get scattered.
Deterministically,
that's reasonable.
You have a charge
here, for example,
and these are charged particles.
They repel and they get
scattered like that.
So you could say,
OK, this contribution
is going to go into a
particular angle, the omega.
So I can think of
this as contributing
to the differential cross
section at an angle omega,
or some contribution to the
total cross section that
would come from
integrating and adding up
all these contributions
as you vary this thing.
So if I want to compute
how much this contributes
to the cross section--
estimate the classical
contribution.
Estimate the classical
contribution d sigma to sigma
from a single partial wave--
single partial wave-- if
I consider a partial wave
with some value of l.
Think of a partial wave
with a fixed value of l.
Then, I have fixed
the impact parameter.
If I change l by one
unit, the impact parameter
changes a little bit.
Think of this as
the b of a given l--
b of a given l.
And this delta b or db--
I'll call it delta
b with capital.
Delta b.
As they change in b
for delta l equal 1.
You see, each partial wave
corresponds to a different l.
Classically, there's
no quantization.
So I must think of
an impact parameter.
And the partial wave corresponds
to the thickness of this thing
when the thickness will
correspond to a change of b,
because l has changed one.
So you can think of
concentric cylinders.
The l equals 0 partial wave,
the l equal 1 partial wave,
all of those are cylinders.
And they all contribute areas.
This is the area that
is going to get--
all the particles
are going to scatter.
So this little thin
cross-sectional area
here is the contribution
to the differential cross
section from this partial wave
in the classical approximation.
So let's do this.
So b of l is equal to l over k.
And delta b is the change
in b when l changes by 1.
So delta b is 1 over k.
So what is the
differential cross section?
The classical-- classical--
it's this area.
This is the area
of the beam that
is going to be scattered
in that partial wave.
So it's going to
be 2 pi b delta b.
And this is 2 pi l
over k times 1 over k.
And that's not so bad.
This is-- I'll write it as 1
over 4, 4 pi over k squared--
the k squared came
out right-- times 2l.
I wrote it like that because--
here it is-- what the
quantum theory tells you
the partial wave contribution
to the cross section is
4 pi over k squared 2l plus 1.
That's pretty much it.
And the classical estimate
gives you one fourth of that.
So pretty nice that
everything works out.
And that there is
a correspondence.
And there is a way to
estimate partial contributions
to the cross section
from classical arguments.
So that's our discussion of
the physics of phase shifts
and the physics of
input parameters
and l and your intuition
that you must have to them.